hey cinephiles this is js with movie
clips here with a review of richard
linklater's highly anticipated film
boyhood
since i was first awed and inspired by
writer director richard linklater's 1991
film slacker i've had a constant
impression of the creativity and
flexibility found in american cinema's
independent scene in recent years
linklater fans have caught wind of the
12-year project an enticement that
linked later along with an undisclosed
cast and crew have been hatching since
2002 when it was revealed that this
passion project was boyhood essentially
the story of one boy played by one actor
going from first grade to graduating
high school expectations were high and
hats were already off to the very
attempt itself since premiering at
sundance this year and winning in the
berlin international film festival
boyhood has built a wave of praise going
in with so much anticipation and
expectation can prove to be a perilous
viewing but from the very first shot of
a six-year-old boy staring up into the
clouds and daydreaming his after-school
time away i was transported back to a
time and a place when my worries were
few and my future was as limitless as
the big blue sky link later threw his
dice and gambled on elder coltrane to
play the film's titular boy mason
coltrane lacks the charisma and style of
your typical adolescent actor but that
turns out to be pitch perfect for this
endeavor mason is curious yet shy making
him both relatable and a canvas to
project our own childhoods upon he forms
philosophies and theories over the years
it wouldn't be a link later film without
that and when he is comfortable enough
to share those with someone we feel
privileged to have gained that trust if
anyone ever wants to know what it's like
for a kid to grow up in america during
the turn of the millennium i am going to
show them boyhood from standing in a
midnight line donned in cosplay for the
release of the new harry potter book to
the physical freedom offered by our
bicycle and then later our first car
boyhood skips a stone along the lake of
our collective adolescence during its
nearly three hour running time it's
impossible to touch on every inch of the
surface but there's a rippling effect
that reminds us it's all part of the
bigger picture link later's daughter
lorelei plays mason's older sister at
times you could have told me i was
watching a candid documentary and i
would have believed you and who's to say
it doesn't slip into that territory at
times the sibling animosity amidst the
unconditional love is a key component to
this film it's called boyhood but
there's plenty of girlhood to observe as
well then there's the parenthood angle
opening up an entire other plane to
explore patricia arquette plays their
ever present mother she's divorced from
their father who is played by ethan
hawke his is a supporting role both for
the film and the children's sake but
hawk breathes new life onto the screen
every time he shows up this is
undoubtedly due to hawk's familiarity
with the drill after being part of link
later's other decade spanning project
the before sunrise series boyhood
foregoes montages and focuses instead on
individual scenes and moments linklater
has always been a dialogue driven
filmmaker and we learn most through the
countless interactions mason and his
family encounter the film still finds
time and opportunity to showcase 50
different era appropriate songs each a
touchstone in its timeline from
coldplay's yellow to arcade fires deep
blue where were we when we first heard
these songs this group driven
achievement reaches heights very few
films have even attempted to grasp it's
somewhere between dazed and confused and
the tree of life and his portrayal of
the precious years of childhood and the
bittersweet closing curtain of our
teenage years as the characters grow up
before our eyes we witness the miracle
of cinema link later has found a way to
put time in a bottle and distribute that
this elixir of life may be the best film
you see this year boyhood comes to
select theaters on july 11th and expands
to more theaters on july 18th it's one
of the best films you'll see this year
for movie clips i'm j.s thanks for
watching
you